acá no tenía familia en chino
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en química
[Música]
para ti
y más
no
bueno
[Música]
esto
esto cambió mi vida
en 2007
para ser más precisos del 29 de octubre
del 2007 nace mi hija
y ese día
he decidido abandonar mi área de confort
tenía un contrato excelente con sony atv
music publishing
y toda la infraestructura que requería
para lo que yo pensaba que en ese
momento era
mi abrigo miembro
[Música]
los juguetes
de niño tuve otro tipo jamás tuve estos
artilugios tan potentes
de repente un día
me vi convertido en eso
como llega a un ser humano a los 33 años
a transformarse dejar la guitarra
dejar los sintetizadores dejar todo
aquel instrumento que te hace sentir
poderoso como músico como compositor
estaba cansado de mí
estaba cansado de mis crisis de ansiedad
y estaba cansado sobre todo de la jaula
en la que me había metido
el juguete sin duda
es un medio de conexión esto hoy día es
un arma
no sólo para mí sino para nuestros
alumnos de halloween art center
que entre otras cosas tienen autismo
asperger
síndrome de dawn
todo lo que causa también el abuso
sexual
que son síntomas muy parecidos a los del
autismo
como es posible que un arma como esta
puede ayudar
las artes son ciencias exactas y hemos
olvidado eso
me encontraba en el año 2012
habiendo abandonado casi todos los
instrumentos excepto la guitarra y me
tiene un viaje de tres meses por europa
que inició en alemania y en alemania yo
todavía tenía una guitarra no me he dado
cuenta que pueda tener esto
que ahorita hice una mini presentación
de lo que puede hacer
no estaba mal tener la guitarra porque
la guitarra si hay algún guitarristas
sabrá utilización anuncia es una forma
de comunicarse diferente llegue a
islandia en reykjavík tuve una
presentación en un lugar que se llama
bad taste que es la compañía de discos
de björk no había una persona y guitarra
la gente tenía juguetes
y yo estaba con mi guitarra
y después de una carrera de años atrás
de haber tenido este contrato de que les
hablaba con sony
en donde la guitarra y estos
instrumentos serán la base veía que no
tenía conexión con la gente en islandia
me estaban sobrando cosas y me estaban
faltando algunas que ya tenían
como sucede la conexión de quitar estos
instrumentos agarrar juguetes y entrar
en el mundo del down que es lo que les
vengo a compartir hoy mi experiencia en
el autismo mi experiencia como alumno y
como maestro dentro del down y del
autismo
es increíble
que habiendo hecho
cualquier cantidad debemos con
instrumentos formales los cuales son
bellísimos golpean
no podía trascender más allá de mi
frontera quizás algún otro país los dejo
y esto me lleva afuera y entonces hay
una nominación a una beca increíble que
se llama saliendo lucas artist residence
que gano
aunque no creo en esta cuestión de la
competencia pero esto es como el nombre
las ganas no y entonces llegó este
centro de artes que se llama montalvo
art centre que está en las montañas
entre san francisco y oakland california
y empiezo a experimentar con todos mis
compañeros con juguetes es una
residencia artística donde había desde
chefs de arte bailarinas escénicos como
yo músicos todo tipo de artistas que te
cual se imaginan eran mis ratones de
laboratorio y nos sentábamos con estos
juguetes si algún día van a hello
between arts center manifestar que
tenemos un mar de juguetes los que no
tuve de niños los tengo hoy
estaba dando un performance y sucedió
algo brutalmente increíble había tres
artistas que me estaban viendo
estos tres artistas
uno de ellos está acá atrás en esta foto
y yo veía que me veían de manera
diferente mi audiencia
me habían echado el ojo para llevarme
con ciertos engaños a un centro de arte
llamado browser center a ser instructor
yo no sabía eso yo nunca busqué de
entrar en el mundo del down del autismo
de las personas esto no sea yo choqué en
ese mundo a través de los juguetes
es corto el tiempo para poder abarcar
todo lo que tiene que ver con el down
con el autismo con el asperger a luz
sexual
y es obligatorio llegar a estas
preguntas como vemos y como vivimos la
discapacidad es un tema
es un tema
porque de hecho de este lado y de aquel
lado sufrimos discriminación
por muchas cosas pero imagínense una
persona con autismo una persona con dawn
ni siquiera se puede parar aquí a
decirte que estás discriminando
y eso es grave
porque hay un ayuno
hay una cantidad de gente
con diferencias neuronales que es como
le hemos llamado nosotros en el
instituto
el autismo a las perfecto es que están
en sus casas
escondidos guardados no por pena sino
porque no hay programas suficientes en
el país no hay programa suficiente en
latinoamérica para poder exponerlos para
poder mimetizarnos con ellos
estábamos en querétaro en el museo de la
ciudad y yo iba a dar un performance
para personas con síndrome down y todo
esto y jesús noyola un curador y
director del festival internacional de
teatro me dice rick yo creo que hay algo
mal en lo que estás haciendo
qué va a ver man ya dejé todo lo demás
no tengo mi instituto tenemos
voluntarios hay instructores y me dijo
algo que me cambió nuevamente el chip
hace dos años y es todos tenemos
necesidades especiales como seres
humanos cuando se lee muy fácil pero en
realidad cuando lo pensamos bien dices
'wow cuántos de aquí tienen depresión
menor mayor
no hay necesidad de que levanten la mano
todos lo sabemos esa es una necesidad
sumamente especial y eso sí es una
enfermedad
a diferencia del down o el autismo el
asperger que es una condición de vida
entonces a mí me cambió mucho esto y
abrimos hello between para la gente
común y corriente o para los que nos
hacemos llamar malamente normales eso no
existe
esta foto es muy bella la captó mi hija
hace algunos años
en una de nuestras terapias en algún
museo
y después de verla en verdad alguien me
preguntó qué diferencia
noten el autismo lo pregunto
directamente lo ven yo no noto notan
algo en mí bueno
posiblemente sí
cuando estaba en oakland me dicen los
instructores es muy probable que seas
candidato a tener tdh trastorno por
déficit de atención e hiperactividad por
eso el tartamudeo y lancia de todo estoy
aquí cualquiera se está identificando en
este momento con el th cualquiera
qué haces si tienes th que así si tienes
asperger
la difícil
buscas
cómo utilizar sus ventajas
y entonces dejas de lado toda la
problemática de vida que has venido
cargando teniendo normalmente cuando
vamos al psicólogo al psiquiatra nos
sientan y no está mal pero es viejo ya
esto que voy a decir y escarbamos en el
problema de que rayos le sirven una
terapia escarbar en el problema de un
ser humano si lo que voy a hacer es
meter mi mano más y más y entonces hello
between nos dimos cuenta de eso a través
del tv hd el director
dijimos no yo no puedo buscando más a
eso adentro vamos a buscar lo que sí
brillan y vamos a buscar lo que sí
brillante en ti en ellos
ok
el maestro joe dispensa que es un
neurólogo muy reconocido en todo el
mundo y además
es un practicante de física cuántica de
teoría cuántica yo empecé a estudiarlo y
dice algo sumamente valioso e importante
adquirir conocimiento nuevo nos mantiene
en constante evolución
[Música]
en este vídeo estamos dos personas
evidentemente estoy yo con el avatar que
me inventé para poder fluir dentro del
halo between
porque después de tener a mis ratones de
experimento que eran mis amigos me tuve
que someter a ser instructor de artistas
que por mucho superaban mis capacidades
como artista
en el vídeo anterior estoy yo con dan
miller dan miller ha expuesto en todo el
planeta es esta persona que tiene el
casco a quien le estoy pasando el papel
este hombre en la actualidad
exhiben moma exhiben guggenheim y en
todos los museos del planeta y yo me
sentía en total desventaja frente a él y
en verdad yo soy su maestro instructor
no esto también está mal yo no soy
instructor de nadie yo no soy maestro de
nadie
yo soy parte de algo y ese parte de algo
se llama hayley between
halloween es una herramienta humana para
poder ser y esto es verdad
estamos cumpliendo 10 años de existir
como hello between y hasta ahora en
verdad hasta ahora hemos entendido que
hallú between no es claro que es una
institución pero en verdad como el
secreto no lo es en realidad es una
herramienta porque lo hemos visto en las
personas que han pasado por genio
between en repetidas ocasiones en
instructores que se convierten en
alumnos en alumnos que se convierte en
instructores en mí
y en la oportunidad de poderlo ofrecer
en general al mundo
el performance consiste más o menos en
esto
y en poder ser
en llevar al corazón
el niño en sacar la parte lúdica de ahí
en poder todo lo que no puedo decir
afuera
porque sería extraño poderlo hacer a
través de las artes repito las artes son
ciencias exactas ahora mismo estamos
escribió un ensayo larguísimo sobre eso
porque nos han dicho por qué no escriben
sobre dawn porque no escriben sólo sobre
autismo es que no hay mucho que escribir
sobre eso
en realidad hemos tratado a más de 100
150 personas con down autismo asperger y
hoy día si me preguntaran qué es el
asperger qué es el autismo yo estoy
incapacitado para decirlo
claro que hay una explicación lógica
pero es la fácil y esto no se trata de
eso
la frase que les comentaba del doctor
joe dispensa teórico cuántico y
neurólogo es esta y es importante
salimos de la universidad y que
pasábamos al trabajo rápidamente
y entonces ya no hay ya no hay
conocimiento nuevo adquirido ya es la
práctica del conocimiento que adquirimos
en la carrera y en el mejor de los casos
en los doctorados y maestrías pero
llegas a los 30 años y entonces
qué aprendiste a repetir
evolucionar es una de nuestras
responsabilidades no solo cuando haya
asperger o cuando hay autismo es en
general para alcanzar un nivel óptimo de
felicidad hacia adentro y hacia fuera
hagamos células es el mensaje final que
les voy a dejar
porque no sirve de mucho que les cuente
todo esto en 15 minutos sino que podemos
hacer sentados desde ahí estoy seguro
que en la audiencia hay personas que
conocen o tienen en sus familias
personas con autismo que es una pandemia
ahora asperger síndrome de down
y cosas diferentes
cómo se hacen estas células ok
alguna persona de ustedes tiene un
familiar cercano con autismo
con síndrome de dawn
no logro ver desde acá pero bueno vamos
a suponer que hay ayuno
tú en tu familia haces una célula que es
hacer unas células globe y twin una
célula hello between es juntarte primero
con tu entorno familiar hermanos hijos
dios con la primera capa con la que
convive un chico con esta característica
de vida la persona que requiere terapia
no es del chico el chico requiere estar
en acción e interacción
practicar equidad e igualdad pero en
casa requerimos células y si hay otra
mano levantada por allá
estas dos células se juntan después de
un mes y entonces ya no nada más de la
experiencia de un lado sino la
experiencia de dos familias y de tres y
de cuatro y en ese momento se forma una
comunidad
que se puede llamar comunidad de salud o
comunidad como quieran y se empieza a
hablar y se empieza a compartir de las
vivencias no nada más de familias entre
autismo de las vivencias entre autismo
asperger síndrome de down o th
la igualdad no es otra cosa que
reconocer que tú y yo somos diferentes
eso es igualdad
la equidad es la parte difícil
la equidad es poner en práctica algo que
van a ver en este momento es yo que
tengo esto a favor te doy una plataforma
para que puedas elegir pero lo que me
falta a mí tú me lo das para podernos
nivelar les quiero presentar a alguien
que fue nuestra alumna hasta hace poco y
hoy día es nuestra instructora en hello
between y ella es marta
de nuestro segundo por favor
les pido un aplauso
para la nueva
instructor a saludar nos puede aprender
un poco la luz
mira y público
de públicos
que están las leyes
ok
les vamos a una probada de lo que marta
y yo hacemos con nuestros saludos
[Música]
sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y ahora
sí
[Música]
sí no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
class
sí
[Música]
aquí
sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
yo
ya ya
i
salió bien
ah
i
[Música]
con su show
marta
[Música]
así
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a marta
mira los los ojos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para que la discusión es justamente eso
no es jalar los a ellos escalarlo
nosotros al mundo de ellos gracias a sus
halloween
[Aplausos]
se mete aquí